[Musique]
bonsoir
la mixité ce n'est pas gagné
il y à un mois j'étais un dîner avec un
de mes amis qui a eu tous les pouvoirs
dans la vie inspecteur des finances
directeur de cabinet d'un ministre de
premier ministre je ne citerai pas son
nom directeur d'une banque et il me dit
à cause de toi ma retraite est foutu
j'ai compris qu'il faisait allusion à
l'arrivée des quotas dans les conseils
d'administration la loi va prendre effet
en février prochain et cette loi ne fait
pas que des heureux
parce que il a fallu imposer cette loi
mais si la loi n'était pas imposé
aujourd'hui nous ne ferions 190 année
pour atteindre la parité en france je
serais trop vieille pour pouvoir
l'apprécier en italie un peu plus de 800
mais c'est une autre histoire
beaucoup d'hommes aujourd'hui dans tous
les secteurs économiques politiques dans
les secteurs privé public
10 il n'y en a que pour les femmes
il ose dire ça après avoir eu tous les
pouvoirs dans la vie je ne crois pas
pour autant que mon ami ou les hommes
aujourd'hui soit plus misogyne qu'avant
réellement pas mais ils ne supportent
pas pour autant cette montée en
puissance des femmes
moi non plus je ne suis pas pour les
quotas parce que je suis pour la
compétence comme tout le monde ici
mais à un moment il fallait y arriver il
y a
longtemps très longtemps et je viens de
lire un livre américain de nicole
bacharan qui explique ça très très bien
dans son livre du sexe aux états unis et
qui explique très bien à quel point les
femmes ont dû se battre pour que nous
soyons là ce soir et pour que je sois
ici et faire ce que j'ai fait il y a eu
des femmes qui nous ont montré
chemin et qui nous ont aidés à être ce
que nous sommes aujourd'hui mais ce
combat que nous menons attire son
corollaire de gens qui ne supportent pas
cette montée en puissance des femmes
c'est pourquoi je prône aujourd'hui un
féminisme qui ne soit plus un féminisme
d'affrontement mais un féminisme plus
apaisées et que j'appelle un féminisme
pragmatique parce que l'affrontement ce
féminisme d'affrontements n'apportera
rien de bien à notre société il y a trop
de sujets d'affrontement
aujourd'hui dans le monde et ici aussi
en particulier en france
suis demandée souvent alors que ça fait
dix ans que nous connaissons les
chiffres et les avantages économiques de
la mixité et je me suis demandé très
souvent pourquoi il fallait encore re
dire et redire et je pense qu'il ya une
nécessité à le redire
pour l'ingénieur la jeune génération des
femmes pour ma fille sa fille
les chiffres suivants qui ont été dits
un petit peu tout à l'heure lorsqu'il y
a plus de trois femmes dans les conseils
d'administration
les résultats économiques des sociétés
sont supérieures sont égaux ou
supérieurs à 6% et un autre chiffres
d'une étude mckinsey qui est sorti
l'année dernière au moment du women's
forum
si la parité dans le monde étaient
respectées d'ici à 2025 le pays des
mondiale augmenterait entre 12000 et 28
mille milliards de dollars
il faut savoir cela pour comprendre
l'intérêt que nous avons tous à une
mixité mais à une mixité apaisé et ce
féminisme apaisé parce que nous ne
pouvons pas vivre dans ce climat et dans
cette complexité que cette relation
amène moi même j'ai adopté très
longtemps les codes du masculin et on
disait de moi que je dirigeais comme un
mec
et c'était vrai je vais beaucoup
regretté aujourd'hui et je me suis
beaucoup posé de questions d'autant plus
qu'une partie de ma carrière a été
consacrée aux femmes puisque j'ai créé
le women's forum
il y à 14 ans savez vous pourquoi j'ai
créé le women's forum parce que
j'entendais parler du world economic
forum à davos
vous savez cet endroit qui réunit tous
les ans en janvier
les dirigeants de ce monde tout le monde
disait qu'on pensait l'avenir à davos
moi aussi je pensais que je pensais
l'avenir donc les voulu y aller je me
suis inscrite je n'ai jamais eu de
réponse à ma demande
j'étais prête à payer cher pourtant pour
y aller je me suis interrogé j'ai
interrogé des copines qui allait mais
elles me disent mais oui mais quid une
femme
ah oui toi aussi oui mais nous on
travaille dans des gros groupes
toi tu dirige une pme et à davos ils ne
savent pas ce qu'est une pme donc les
femmes représentaient 4 à 5% du public
de davos et les pme il les ignoraient je
suis bretonne est têtu et je me mets en
colère parfois et la colère m'a fait
écrire le concept du women's forum
j'ai adoré faire ce forum j'ai adoré
parce que ensemble avec ces femmes et
quelques hommes et c'est la raison
d'ailleurs pour laquelle dès la première
année j'ai eu carlos ghosn gérard
mestrallet le président d'alcoa états
unis le président de mci nzay mohammed
yunus
j'invitais les hommes parce que j'avais
compris que sans les hommes
un forum de femmes resteraient d'un
forum de femmes et un forum de femmes ça
fait pas avancer les choses
c'est assez curieux mais il y a quinze
jours j'étais en tunisie et les hommes
sont venus les officiels le chef du
gouvernement les ministres
ils sont venus mais ne sont pas restés à
un moment je me lève puisqu'il partait
et jeudi au mini un ministre important
de l'économie
je vous ne restez pas il dit ben non je
laisse ça les femmes entre elles je ne
suis vous êtes ministre de l'économie
dans un pays qui a des difficultés et où
les femmes ont eu un rôle majeur et ne
voulait pas les écouter ils sont partis
il m'a regardé dédaigneux et tous les
hommes sont partis et huit jours avant
j'étais à un forum en france qui
s'appelle africa 2016 formidable
formidable c'était pour l'afrique
c'était très bien
95 % du public étaient des hommes et
dans ses 95 % d'hommes 80 % étaient des
mâles blancs de plus de 50 ans cherchez
l'erreur
quand on sait larges des dirigeants en
afrique aujourd'hui
et quand on sait le rôle des femmes il y
a quelque chose d'anormal
et donc je vous reparlerai de mes
propres quotas après donc j'ai fait ce
wee man ce forum avec beaucoup de
bonheur et women's forum s'est développé
très vite peut-être un peu trop vite
pour la pme que j'avais et je les cds à
publicis pour qu'il puisse continuer sa
route
il continue aujourd'hui c'est difficile
[Applaudissements]
j'ai fait un burn-out ça n'arrive pas
qu'aux hommes quand annonce que disait
marie christine tout à l'heure j'ai mis
du temps d'en sortir
je m'en suis sorti parce que je suis
allé sur le terrain je suis allée entre
autres en rdc
et là j'ai vu ce qu'il y avait de pire
de ce qu'on pouvait faire aux femmes aux
enfants aux petites filles et je me suis
dit que mon problème n'était pas
important finalement qu'il y avait
beaucoup plus importants que moi quand
je suis revenu en france
j'ai écrit un livre femmes si vous osiez
le monde s'en porterait mieux et j'ai
décidé de recréer une entreprise parce
que c'est la seule chose que je sache
faire et j'ai créé les forums oh non la
france et le forme osons la france je
les crée parce que j'en avais marre de
mon pays marre de ce que j'entendais
dire l'étranger marquant soit toujours
en train de se plaindre alors qu'il y
avait des choses c'est difficile
ailleurs et j'ai développé cette
entreprise très vite trop vite là aussi
c'est le problème
une personnalité qui à un moment
n'arrive pas à lutter contre cette
énergie il faut savoir la canaliser et
j'ai développé très vite cette
entreprise est malheureusement l'année
dernière il est arrivé un gros pépin
mais je vous promets je vais pas pleurer
j'ai déposé le bilan de toutes mes
boîtes trois boîtes en neuf mois j'ai
vécu une chose extrêmement difficile qui
m'a amené à écrire et lire un livre qui
s'appelle forcer le destin et le sous
titre du livre c'est j'ai choisi le
succès et l'échec m'a rattrapé et j'ai
fait dans ce travail d'écriture un
travail sur à la fois mon propre passé
mais c'est aussi sur la situation des
femmes face à un échec et je me suis
rendu compte que nous n'avions pas
toutes à que nous n'avions pas les mêmes
réactions que nous traînions cette
culpabilité
cependant si nantes qu'est la nôtre et
que ce manque de confiance que nous
avons en nous pouvait très vite remonter
à la surface
et ça a été quelque chose de terrible à
vivre et tout le monde qui me voyaient
comme cette fille réussit tout ce
qu'elle marche évidemment ce que je fais
fait du bruit
parce que j'y mets l'énergie que j'ai et
du coup les chèques est encore plus
violent et cet échec il y a peu de gens
qui ont pu le partager parce que les
gens continuent en faisant tout un échec
mais non tu as très bonne mine
non mais c'est pas comme ça la vie c'est
pas parce qu'on a bonne mine
quand on ne va pas on va bien on peut
cacher des choses alors du coup j'ai
décidé après cet échec ne savait pas
encore que j'allais m'occuper de femmes
en afrique mais je m'occupais d'un
collège dans le 9 3 parce que simone
veil m'avait présenté il y a quelques
années
une de mes amies qui présente je crois
j'espère ici samia essabaa qui est
professeur dans un collège dans le 9-3 à
noisy-le-sec à lycée professionnel et
samia se bat tous les ans pour emmener
ses élèves
ces jeunes comme elle dit ses enfants
garçons et filles dans des pays faire
des pays difficiles pour montrer à ces
jeunes que ce qu'ils vivent eux
cette mixité si difficile dans les
banlieues parce que ça n'est pas qu'un
problème du cac 40 c'est un problème est
un problème de bourgeois la mixité c'est
un problème d'éducation
c'est un problème que nous avons autour
de nous et qui explique beaucoup
beaucoup de choses aujourd'hui en france
et dans les quartiers difficiles et
samia se bat alors ce que je fais pour
elle parce que je tape mes copains
bourgeois je leur demande de l'argent là
j'ai peut-être vous tapez là après parce
que le prochain voyage
on les emmène à on va faire un voyage à
auschwitz
on les emmène le 6 mars prochain parce
que il y à une nécessité à ce que les
jeunes d'aujourd'hui voir qu'il y a eu
des choses encore plus difficiles et ça
peut peut-être relativiser leur propre
tristesse leurs propres souffrances et
leurs propres drames et cette mixité
dans les banlieues je les appréhender
beaucoup au travers de samia et lorsque
l'année dernière j'ai déposé le bilan de
mes boîtes et que je n'avais donc
toujours pas cette idée de relancer une
entreprise parce que j'avais perdu mon
énergie
ça arrive et ça m'est arrivé
j'ai décidé de lancer ce que j'appelle
aujourd'hui le club d improbables club d
un proverbe c'est quoi mais je veux unis
parce que je devrais pas rire parce que
l'origine de çà c'est qu'il y avait les
attentats en france et ça aussi c'est un
sujet d'homme parce qu'on ne voit jamais
les hommes les femmes prendre les armes
ou très rarement et les femmes des
banlieues souffre souffre un point
incroyable
et donc j'ai décidé de les réunir tous
les trimestres la dernière fois c'était
chez l'oréal la prochaine fois séchées
aufeminin.com et jeux réunis avec ces
femmes à peu près 60 70 la dernière fois
on était même 80 30 de mes amis qui
occupent des postes incroyable dans la
vie et je l'aimé ensemble tout
simplement pour qu'elles se connaissent
parce que cette mixité des deux côtés du
périphérique est nécessaire à l'
équilibre dont nous avons besoin là
aussi en france et une fois que j'avais
mis ça en place mais il fallait que je
gagne ma vie parce que j'avais perdu
beaucoup d'argent et que voilà il
fallait que je travaille
et donc j'ai décidé de créer à la
demande d'ami africaine women in africa
oui made in africa c'est un forum
économique mondial de femmes qui va se
tenir en ethiopie en mai prochain
je pars dimanche pour rencontrer le
gouvernement pour nous assurer de la
sécurité de l'obtention des visas et je
rencontre j'étais la semaine dernière au
nigeria je rencontre des femmes dans
tous les pays où je vais et je suis en
train de les mettre dans un écrin
network mondiale parce que je pense que
le monde de demain sera un monde
beaucoup plus apaisé lorsqu'il y aura
des hommes et des femmes ensemble et
tout à l'heure je vous parlais de mes
quotas et bien mes quotas c'est que pour
ce que pour que ce forum
we made in africa tiennent la route et
soit considérée j'ai décidé qu'il y
aurait 25 % d'hommes donc messieurs si
vous voulez venir vous nous le fait
savoir
on est prêt à vous inviter parce que je
veux qu'il y ait 25 % d'hommes pour que
les hommes comprennent qu'un forum en
afrique dans un pays qui va nous
apporter beaucoup
d'ailleurs nous avons un programme qui
s'appelle la rivers innovation' oublions
toujours que l'afrique peut nous
apporter beaucoup et que ça peut aller
dans ce sens
et pas seulement dans celui là et c'est
ça que je voudrais faire aujourd'hui
c'est mon combat de demain mais est ce
que c'est un combat je ne crois pas
c'est une envie profonde que j'ai d'un
féminisme apaisé d'un féminisme
pragmatique et je voudrais finir en vous
donnant un proverbe africain
les poules savent quand le jour se lève
mais elle laisse au coq le soin de
l'annoncer
je vous remercie
[Musique]